Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Et si nous partagions ensemble
une expérience de réalité virtuelle ?
Imaginez-vous enfiler un casque
de réalité virtuelle comme celui-là,
avec des écrans intégrés
juste devant les yeux.
Ici.
On l’enfile un peu comme un masque
de ski ou de plongée - comme ça.
Vous regardez autour de vous.
Et ça y est,
vous voilà immergé
dans un monde virtuel très réaliste.
Vous êtes dans une pièce
qui ressemble à un bureau,
peut-être un peu comme le vôtre.
Sur la gauche, une plante verte
est posée dans un coin.
Une table située juste devant vous.
À droite, un poster est accroché au mur.
Maintenant, j’entre dans la scène,
je m’adresse à vous,
je vous demande de regarder votre main.
Vous baissez la tête
et vous voyez une main
virtuelle très réaliste, elle aussi,
parfaitement superposée à la vôtre
et qui suit fidèlement
les mouvements de vos doigts.
Pourtant, il y a un détail qui vous gêne
avec cette main, quelque chose qui cloche.
Vous mettez un certain temps
avant de remarquer :
« Ah, ça y est ! »
En fait, un sixième doigt
est apparu juste là, entre votre
annulaire et votre petit doigt.
Incroyable, incroyable.
Maintenant, je vous demande de poser
la main sur la table et de ne plus bouger.
Et moi, avec un pinceau,
je vais venir brosser délicatement,
et successivement,
chacun de vos doigts
dans un ordre aléatoire.
Vous regardez le pinceau qui passe
sur l’un et l’autre de vos doigts
lorsqu’il s’approche du sixième doigt,
là, vous êtes sur vos gardes.
Et pourtant, vous ressentez parfaitement
la caresse des poils du pinceau
sur votre peau.
Vous ressentez donc physiquement
ce doigt en plus.
En quelques minutes, votre cerveau
a donc intégré un membre artificiel.
Voilà tout l’enjeu des expériences que
nous menons dans mon laboratoire :
réussir à vous faire croire
à des chimères,
des choses qui n’existent pas.
Entre nous, je peux vous donner
mon truc de magicien du virtuel.
En réalité, lorsque vous regardez
le pinceau qui passe sur votre 6e doigt,
moi, en fait, je repasse avec mon pinceau
sur votre annulaire.
Et votre cerveau, lui, va projeter
cette sensation tactile
au niveau du sixième doigt.
Et ça marche très bien.
Le plus extraordinaire dans l’expérience,
c’est à la fin :
j’appuie sur un bouton
pour redonner une apparence « normale »
à votre main virtuelle qui redevient
instantanément une main à cinq doigts.
Tout est rentré dans l’ordre,
et pourtant, à ce moment-là,
vous ressentez comme un manque.
Comme si on vous avait coupé un doigt.
Les effets de la réalité virtuelle peuvent
donc être extrêmement puissants.
Et c’est bien parce
qu’ils sont si puissants
que je vous conseille de faire attention
la prochaine fois que vous aurez
à choisir un avatar.
Vous savez, c’est ce personnage
qui vous représente sur Internet
ou dans un monde virtuel.
En théorie, le choix est infini.
Quel corps virtuel, quel personnage,
allez-vous choisir ?
Vous pouvez opter pour un corps
plus grand, plus petit,
plus corpulent, plus mince,
plus musclé, moins musclé.
Vous pouvez même en profiter pour essayer
de changer de couleur de peau
ou changer de genre.
Après tout, c'est l'occasion.
Mais faites attention parce que
cet avatar, ses apparences,
ses caractéristiques,
vont ensuite influencer
de manière considérable
votre comportement dans le monde virtuel.
Par exemple, une étude a montré que,
si vous vous incarnez
dans un avatar d’un enfant de 6 ans,
avec un corps plus petit,
vous allez vous mettre progressivement
à vous comporter de manière
un peu plus enfantine.
Vous allez vous mettre à parler avec
une voix à la tonalité un peu plus aiguë,
un peu comme si vous régressiez,
un peu comme si vous viviez une cure
de jouvence éclair en réalité virtuelle.
Et dans une autre étude,
des chercheurs espagnols ont montré que,
si vous vous incarnez dans un avatar
qui ressemble fidèlement
à Albert Einstein, le célèbre physicien,
et que l’on vous demande de réaliser
des tests cognitifs, des casse-têtes,
eh bien, le simple fait d’être
dans la peau d’Einstein
va permettre d’améliorer vos résultats
de manière significative,
un peu comme si vous deveniez
plus intelligent en réalité virtuelle.
Ça peut donc aller très loin.
On appelle ça d’ailleurs l’effet Proteus,
en hommage à une divinité
de la mythologie grecque, Protée,
qui aurait la capacité
de changer de forme,
ce qui évoque l’influence de votre avatar
sur votre comportement,
sur votre identité,
qui elle-même devient
changeante, malléable,
dans le monde virtuel et même parfois
dans le monde réel,
parce que cet effet Proteus peut persister
quelque temps après l’immersion,
après que vous avez retiré votre masque.
« C’est bien beau tout ça, »
vous allez me dire,
« mais à quoi ça sert ? »
Eh bien, je pense que les applications les
plus prometteuses de ces technologies,
dont celle sur laquelle on travaille
d’arrache-pied dans mon laboratoire,
sont celles qui concernent
le domaine médical,
en particulier pour les thérapies
et la rééducation.
Prenons l’exemple de la crise
de la Covid-19.
Nous avons tous été touchés
plus ou moins durement par cette maladie.
Nous avons tous une relation qui a
contracté la Covid-19 sous une forme grave
qui a nécessité une hospitalisation
en réanimation,
c’est-à-dire avec une intubation
et donc dans le coma.
Lorsqu’on se réveille du coma,
on se retrouve extrêmement affaibli,
la masse musculaire a fondu,
il est devenu pratiquement impossible
de se lever, de marcher,
de s’alimenter tout seul.
Il va donc falloir réapprendre
tous ces gestes du quotidien.
Cette situation n’est pas uniquement
vécue par les malades de la Covid-19,
mais par pratiquement la moitié
des patients qui passent en réanimation,
en France et partout ailleurs,
sous intubation.
Le problème est que dans ces services,
il existe aujourd’hui finalement
assez peu de moyens
pour se rééduquer, pour faire
de l’exercice physique dans cet état,
notamment parce que si vous commencez
à pratiquer un exercice physique,
le simple fait de se mettre debout,
votre cœur n’est plus habitué
et vous risquez de faire une syncope.
C’est pourquoi,
avec mes collègues chercheurs,
nous avons développé
une application très innovante,
basée justement sur la réalité virtuelle
et sur les avatars.
Je vous propose de vous mettre un instant
à la place d’un de ces patients.
Vous venez de vous réveiller,
il y a quelques heures,
dans une chambre d’hôpital.
Vous êtes sous le choc.
Vous êtes perfusé, relié à une machine
qui surveille en permanence votre état,
très fatigué, pratiquement
incapable de bouger.
Les heures sont vraiment longues.
Et ce matin, on vous propose
de tester notre dispositif.
Vous êtes équipé d’un casque
de réalité virtuelle comme celui-là,
mais directement dans votre lit d’hôpital.
Dans la scène, vous êtes incarné dans
un avatar qui vous ressemble plutôt bien.
Vous êtes assis sur une chaise virtuelle,
dans une chambre d’hôpital virtuelle
assez similaire à la vôtre.
Lorsque vous êtes prêt,
le soignant lance la simulation.
À ce moment-là, votre avatar se lève
et fait quelques pas.
Là, c’est une sensation très puissante
parce que c’est un peu
comme si vous regardiez un film
en étant vraiment
dans la peau de l’acteur.
Un peu comme si vous voyiez tout ce
qu’il fait à travers ses propres yeux.
Vous vous voyez donc vous lever
et marcher pour la première fois
depuis bien longtemps.
Ensuite, l’aventure continue
de plus belle :
votre avatar ouvre une porte
et sort de la chambre -
sort hors de l’hôpital.
Devant vous, un long ponton en bois
s’étend sur plusieurs centaines de mètres.
Vous commencez à marcher
tranquillement dessus
pour parcourir un paysage magnifique,
tantôt une prairie,
tantôt une forêt, tantôt une plage.
Dépaysement garanti.
Pendant tout ce temps, vous vous
voyez donc en train de marcher
dans un corps qui marche,
dans un corps qui remarche,
alors qu’en réalité,
pendant tout ce temps,
vous êtes resté allongé
dans votre lit d’hôpital.
Cette séance de marche
par procuration virtuelle,
nous allons la répéter pendant neuf jours,
tous les jours, à raison
de dix minutes par session.
Notre hypothèse, c’est
qu’en se voyant ainsi en train de marcher
et en imaginant qu’on est en train
de le faire tous les jours,
votre cerveau va réactiver certains
circuits qui sont liés à la locomotion
et qu’il va, d’une certaine manière,
démarrer son processus de rééducation
de manière précoce.
Ainsi, nous espérons que les patients
de la Covid-19 vont pouvoir
récupérer plus rapidement,
se remettre à marcher plus efficacement
tout en améliorant leur moral
et leur confiance dans l’avenir.
Le principe d’une hypothèse, c’est
qu’on ne maîtrise pas le résultat final.
Les essais cliniques ont démarré
au CHU de Rennes il y a un mois -
il y a quelques mois.
Comme dans toute recherche,
on n’aura le résultat
qu’à la fin de l’étude,
c’est-à-dire dans six à douze mois.
Mais ce que je peux vous dire aujourd'hui,
ce que nous savons le 25 septembre 2021,
c’est que tous les soignants
et pratiquement tous les patients
qui ont testé notre outil
souhaitent même pouvoir continuer
de l’utiliser après la fin des essais.
Je ne sais pas si cette hypothèse
va se confirmer, mais j’y crois.
Je suis persuadé que ces technologies
vont permettre d’obtenir,
dans quelques années,
des thérapies différentes,
plus rapides, plus efficaces,
et sûrement plus accessibles pour un grand
nombre de patients partout dans le monde.
Maintenant : et vous ?
Comment réagirez-vous demain,
dans quelques années,
lorsque vous irez à votre tour
chez le médecin, chez le kiné
ou tout simplement chez
votre professeur de danse,
de sport, de théâtre,
lorsqu’elle prendra
un visio-casque comme celui-là
et vous le tendra en vous disant :
« Alors ? Vous êtes prêt
pour votre petite séance ?
Et aujourd’hui, quel corps virtuel,
quel avatar voulez-vous choisir ? »
Eh bien, ce sera à vous de choisir.
En faisant ce choix,
vous détenez les clés,
vous allez devenir acteur de votre propre
transformation dans le monde virtuel
et peut-être aussi dans le monde réel.
À vous de choisir,
mais, souvenez-vous, choisissez bien
parce que maintenant,
vous connaissez les effets profonds
et le pouvoir bien réel de la réalité
virtuelle sur votre cerveau.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)